Ucrania no estaba llamada a ser la gran
protagonista de este foro económico
mundial en davos sin embargo lo que
terminó ocurriendo fue lo contrario y es
que ha sido el plato fuerte del día hoy
en los discursos de los diferentes
líderes mundiales que han participado
por ejemplo la propia olana se lesca la
esposa del presidente polo de mirza
lensky estuvo aquí enviándole un mensaje
al mundo para pedir más cooperación
cooperación en que la Unión Europea ya
le ha prometido tres mil millones de
euros que fueron desembolsados en las
últimas horas y también un paquete
adicional para llegar a 18.000 millones
de euros en lo largo de todo este año
también hay presión sobre Alemania para
que permita el envío de tanques de
fabricación alemana en los leopard que
son bastante utilizados por los
ejércitos en Europa
el canciller olafones estará mañana
presente en ese foro económico mundial y
previo a esta participación ya los
presidentes de Polonia y de lituania le
pidieron que reconsiderara su a la
exportación de estos tanques Alemania ha
sido bastante cautelosa porque cree que
esto podría desencadenar en un conflicto
aún peor y que inclusive podría llegar a
generarse un conflicto entre Rusia y la